you know what's crazy so this whole
thing with five million dollars
i was on fox and friends and we talked
about it and we've raised another
million dollars so we're
shy of six million dollars you give a 10
you give 10 000 which was very nice of
you but
we're at uh uh uh shy of six million you
know what's amazing you know what's the
craziest thing about the story here's
what's the
craziest thing about story one of the
guys gave a hundred thirty seven
thousand dollars
okay now this guy who gave 137 thousand
dollars guess where he's based out of i
told you the story yesterday
he's a corporate lawyer from
india so
in email we ask why are you giving this
137 thousand dollars you don't even live
in america
look at his answer he says you know i'm
giving 137 thousand dollars
because when u.s is at peace the rest of
the world does good
hell yeah when u.s isn't at peace we
feel it
i want to see whatever i whatever i can
do to help unify u.s the rest of us are
going to do better
a corporate attorney from india
gave 137 thousands trickle down social
economics political gold figure
yeah wow what a response have you heard
back from either of the two camps
we're talking right now to you know both
of them you know not yet at the direct
direct contact i'm two away
from the content is that uh is that like
a million rupees why 137 very oddly and
by the way any any money you give today
in the super chat any money you give
today in the super chat 100 percent of
money give today in the super chat's
gonna go to
the the raising of the funds to make
that money go higher whatever you give
give a hundred dollars ten dollars five
hundred dollars a thousand dollars
whatever you give it's gonna go to 100
of uh raising more money to make this
trump obama thing happen by the way i
gotta tell you
more and more people talk about it the
more and more conviction goes higher
that this can
this can happen more and more have you
thought about what the first question
you'd ask
the format i've thought about is the
following and let me tell you what's
that what the what's the one that i'm
most excited about the format is
first hour i'm asking questions second
hour what the audience wanted to ask
questions because it's a long form
third hour i say nothing i just simply
moderate and i sit in the middle and i
say what questions do you guys have for
each other
and they talk the last hour is the one
up that run i'm really looking forward
to
so lady on twitter can pull up this
twitter account and
show what she said whatever she said
many people have said the complete
opposite
on the other side so uh a lot of people
are making videos on youtube
right now talking about should this
happen should not happen people are
writing articles about the three china
websites wrote about this yesterday by
the way just so you know that's what we
want yeah
we have a big chinese following so keep
going keep going right there so
we have this lady who says not this one
go back
uh go up go yeah keep going the
direction you're going okay right there
so she says
president barack obama should go nowhere
near trump for the rest of his life
neither should president biden or any
other honest caring elected officials
you gave his character honesty grace
strength and joy as a world leader the
circus is over happy
birthday early mr president it's more
like happy early birthday mr president
but it's okay
so then she retweets the the fox and
friends deal and then go back up
rochelle riley she's verified so i think
she's an author i said comments like
this is exactly why america is divided
the idea of both sides thinking they're
too holy to sit down with the opposing
party is how we got here
mlk was willing to sit down with just
about anyone to unite america be loyal
to america not just your political party
now guy makes a video says the complete
opposite thing
president trump should never sit down
with president obama because obama is
this obama's how we got you obama's
house divided in america
so this isn't like a one-sided thing
there's both sides that don't want the
other person to sit there
but i'm gonna tell you this here couple
things number one um
who did president obama go meet with in
march of 2015 i want to say
who did he 2015 who did he go meet with
in a country that he went and it was the
first president
since uh grover i know since
uh who was it since the president since
coolidge
that visited cuba he went to sat down in
cuba he was in cuba for three days and
he watched the baseball game with him
with raul castro raul castro
his brother world's like are you kidding
me you're sitting down with a communist
in a regime like cuba and you're willing
to go
laugh and watch a game with them who did
trump go sit down with in
north korea north korea so if trump can
sit
with kim yong-un and obama can sit with
raul castro i am sure they can sit down
with each other i agree
if those two can sit down with those two
guys you can definitely sit down with
each other because this is
the the the the hamster wheel spinning
up there directly wasn't that like
clint and george bush senior i mean
they've developed a great friendship
right now relationships
see different different opposing sides
of
you know free enterprise or free market
system i can
very much see where them sitting down
together
is beneficial i don't necessarily know
if like sitting down with a
tyrannical like despotic leader is is
really that
that good like i don't i don't i don't
think sitting with chavez or sitting
with
role castro or even kim jong-un is
really
this isn't about whether that was good
or not we're not going to go back and
relive that the point is
if you sat with them and half the
country didn't support you sitting with
them
why are you not willing to sit down with
another president like yourself you know
just don't have a conversation about it
before this is they literally
have something in common that what only
four other living people five other
living people have in common
they've shared a space that literally
only uh
actual handful of people can even
remotely understand
um i would love to see it i think it
would it would be
it would it would be history you would
make history now how you can
convince them not to wear earpieces and
not just regurgitate talking points for
three hours and
you know i don't know but i don't i
don't either by the way i don't know
yeah i don't think
by the way here's the other part say
they do that it won't work
it will not work because both will call
the other one out
i don't think that'll work you have to
realize both of them
are pretty sharp and pretty bold neither
one of them are weak
and pushovers you're not dealing with a
biden and you're not dealing with
somebody on the right that's a easy
pushover that you may not want to debate
ryan okay you're dealing with somebody
that you know both of them are
heavyweights of their own side so
they're going to sit down with each
other and they have things to tell each
other great i think both are going to
hold each other accountable
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye